[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike tarico is going to host the
kentucky derby
live from churchill downs that'll be
tomorrow that'll be the fifth time he's
done that
their coverage starts at 2 30 eastern
also part of saturday's
derby show will be mike's championship
discussion with bill belichick
and also bob baffert the six-time
kentucky derby-winning trainer
well let me start with that there mike
uh how did that come up
and what was the topic of conversation
with bill
i i'd love to tell you but the segment's
out of time
with you thanks to talk to you mike have
fun at churchill
thanks [ __ ] i love 2112 great album
thanks for being on have a great weekend
so belichick we see belichick at the
preakness every year uh
baltimore guy loves going to pimlico he
and seth karmann one of the big
horse racing owners have a good
relationship so bill's there every year
and i know that he really enjoys horse
racing and he's won six super bowls
obviously baffert's won the
super bowl of thoroughbred racing
kentucky derby six times
so we you know we've told the bafford
story a hundred different ways so
let's get like let's give this a whirl
so i was out at santa anita in southern
california
interviewed baffert and then we did a
zoom and we zoomed in belichick
it was hysterical bill was great in the
piece which will air on the pre-race
show
belichick laughs tells jokes
he shares his love of horse racing and
bill belichick says we're on to
cincinnati without being prompted which
was sensational
i like i wanted to walk off like this is
the best day ever we got belichick to
say we're on to cincinnati on his own it
was great
so it was just a fun time and it's about
belichick in a different light and
seemed true with bathroom
i am never going to see that side of
bill belichick that everybody keeps
telling me oh you would love it man he
is so
funny i i i've never been around him
when he's let his guard down
so you know maybe one of these days i'll
i'll i'll see that side
well maybe i'll just tune in tomorrow
you can do that yeah and then i'll i'll
see that side
the the highlight of the piece is
bafford comes up with a term about
dealing with you know media attention
all that stuff
and belichick like lights up when
bafford says and he goes
bob i like that i i might steal that for
next year so i'm going to be watching
the belichick press conferences to see
if he steals the bat for a lot the piece
was fun and it was a great
great of bill i'm very appreciative that
he answered our call and was willing to
play along with us
now you did notre dame games this year
the best best player you saw either on
notre dame or against notre dame this
year was who
well it's hard to say trevor lawrence
because he didn't play in the game dj
uncle lalay the guy was gonna replace
lawrence was that was the quarterback
for that game
i would probably say travis etienne
um and notre dame handling for a while i
thought
one of the notre dame players would go
in the first round and that was jeremiah
usu koromoa
i love him as a player versatility you
know that kind of isaiah simmons hybrid
role you can do a lot of things with him
he will not last long in the second
round and if your team gets them uh
this guy he brings it speed
power with that speed and a really smart
kid
and very he loves football and i hate to
run through all the kuiper cliches there
but
uh he fits the bill full time and
whoever gets him will be good and liam
eichenberg the left tackle too there are
a couple of good notre dame players i
think will go
in the second round but opponents i say
etn was the best of the bunch
what is it like hosting when you host a
draft
when when you know there's so many
moving parts there
um like just trying to keep focused
there you know greeny did a great job
last night you know his first
first draft rich eisen's been doing this
for a long long time
but what is that like with information
where it feels like you got
people talking in both of your ears if
you had a third ear they'd be talking
into that as well the crowd noise in
there
as well right right
unfortunately you're talking out of
something else while people are talking
during the draft right yeah you know you
know what dan
it's funny you said that because you
know espn
on their social media put out uh the the
class
photo the legendary class photo of the
sportscenter anchors because rich and
mike were in there
uh and they showed the you know the two
guys were hosting the draft and boomers
sit in the middle and you're in there
and robin
charlie and hope me chris mckendree a
whole bunch of us
and uh i saw that i just reached out to
both rich and mike and said hey good
luck with the draft
i did day two ten times or eleven times
i did
the main set once berman couldn't do the
draft and did i think like seven or
eight nba drafts
and and i texted greeny i said and i'll
be honest with you guys i said look
i said tonight is if you want to think
of anything from the experience of the
chair
it's a night to be chris paul not james
harden
you got to just take it and dish it and
take it and dig it and take an addition
it's not a nice to dribble the ball into
the floor
and step back and jack up shots even
though james james harden's great at
doing that
and um that greenie was true that's all
that's a hard job to do
but the thing always leaves me empty as
a viewer
is as soon as the pick happens half the
audience wants to hear about
how does the guy fit who am i getting
the other half of the audience wants to
get on to the next pick give me the
four-minute run-up to the lions
and you got to see the commercial in
there somewhere so it's always a hard
show to satisfy the viewers but
uh that both networks do a really nice
job doing it it's not easy for sure
what's your favorite draft moment that
you hosted
tom brady i i was on the air for tom
brady
and every year now for the last 10 years
or so
uh the anniversary of the brady pick
which is also belichick's birthday in
late april that clip surfaces on social
media
and i get a number of hey you had hair
back then
yes i did hey guys
piper's hair hasn't changed no it hasn't
but the headline of the thing
um i had a pretty good insight into the
michigan situation i wasn't living there
at that point
i was covering college football and i
was able to kind of put in context that
brady wasn't starting
drew henson was there and kuiper's
analysis of brady
is spot on if you ever get a chance go
back and listen to it
uh kuiper nailed brady on pick 199 in
the draft
21 years ago it was not that he was
going to be the all-time great but
what he could be in the league and the
opportunities that he showed
when he had his time in michigan he's
mike tarico host play-by-play voice nbc
sports nbc football night in america and
the kentucky derby
what do we need to know what's this
audience need to know about tomorrow
all right no super horse but a bunch of
really good ones uh
as many as eight legitimately have a
chance
i had to ask randy moss and jerry bailey
who are i'm on the set with and they're
awesome they've done this for many many
years
and i said guys let's start throwing out
names would you be surprised if this
horse wins or this horse wins and they
said no we won't be
so i i think if you're a handicapper or
better you've got a lot of options
uh in this race a couple of the
headlines essential quality is the
favorite
two-year-old champ undefeated in five
races
trained by brad cox who grew up two
blocks from here nobody from louisville
has ever trained a derby champ
big deal locally bob baffert's going for
his seventh would be the all-time record
he's on his horse is medina spirit
not probably one of the top three or
four maybe in that next group
uh those would be the couple of
headlines to take away but known agendas
the other one i'll throw at you real
quick
he's starting on the rail horses
normally don't win from the one hole in
the 20 horse field
but they've got a new gate that has been
able to
move the number one spot a little bit
off the rail
so the experts think the one has a
better chance this year than in other
years
have you ever ridden a a racehorse no
not a racehorse i did one of those kind
of mule things at grand canyon
like 30 years ago that was good enough
for me very similar
how about you you have it you're too
tall right yeah no i've been on horses
before
oh you have yeah yeah yeah anything good
i mean are you
do you have it i mean were you in a tuck
were you you know uh it wasn't it wasn't
comfortable
no because i like to go bareback
i'm talking about me not the like
there's no saddle like i'm bareback and
that's you know that
why it was a little bit uh uncomfortable
there oh my god
i will tell you this i will say it's the
people in horse racing the trainers the
jocks the grooms they're such good
people they love
they love the horses and this is one of
the few days these three days of the
breeders cup that you really pay
attention it gets on the national scene
but the people who keep this sport code
they did a great job during the pandemic
horse racing didn't stop people had to
take care of the horses the horses
couldn't
go into lockdown for three months you
need to feed them and train them and
work them and stand them up and all that
how many fans tomorrow about a third
around fifty thousand forty five fifty
thousand a third of
the normal deal with the masks no look
it's 147 acre facility
so if any place can social distance it's
churchill dams
mike have fun we'll be watching we
appreciate it uh and uh thanks for
joining us as always
anytime pal have a great weekend that's
the great mike trico he'll be hosting
the kentucky derby live the coverage on
nbc 2 30 eastern of course a
special sit down with bill belichick
he's won
six super bowls in the six-time kentucky
derby winner bob baffert
they sit down together